we begin with the central Gulf Coast
bracing for potentially devastating
flooding from what could become
hurricane
Barry part of that storm system dumped
up to nine inches of rain in three hours
on parts of New Orleans yesterday
Louisiana is already under a state of
emergency hurricane watches are in
effect along the coast up to ten
thousand people have been ordered to
evacuate this morning severe weather
watches stretch from Louisiana to
Florida and at the moment Manuel
Bojorquez is on a levee along the
swollen Mississippi River in New Orleans
many I guess the question I don't
everyone's mind there is are those
levees expected to hold well they are
but they could overtop that's the
potential here we're talking about
possibly up to 18 inches of rain coming
into Louisiana this weekend you
mentioned the already swollen
Mississippi River behind me that
combined with the storm surge could send
the river up to 20 feet this weekend
that's the same height as some of these
levees that protect the city which was
already hit by flash flooding lines of
powerful thunderstorms dumped up to nine
inches of torrential rains over New
Orleans Wednesday in just three hours
turning the streets in Louisiana's
biggest city into small rivers so I
guess I shouldn't we're home trapping
some people inside flooded businesses
and homes along the historic French
Quarter a possible tornado also touched
down I heard a big explosion like sound
and the whole bedroom was blown out and
my wife and dog were kind of but the
rain is the biggest worry going forward
this neighborhood is in one of the
lowest points of New Orleans which is
below sea level so people are used to
some flooding here but they say it's
becoming more and more frequent and they
fear it's their new normal there's
nowhere for it to go and that's kind of
the fear of living in the bowl that we
live in another major concern for many
are the city's drainage pumps you can
look around and see they got a little
twisters in there but
every nine minutes stop twisting so the
pumps not really working at good many of
the levees got a 14 billion dollar
overhaul after Hurricane Katrina in 2005
but some have started to settle and may
not provide the intended protection if
water levels on the Mississippi River
reach historic levels people need to
keep constant vigilance as we move
through the next few days to keep an
idea of what's going on and from there
we can all stay safe the Army Corps of
Engineers says it is working to
reinforce low-lying areas the city says
all but two of its drainage pumps are
operational right now but a large amount
of rain in a short period of time can
overwhelm any system Michelle I know it
looks like you're on the West Bank
all of all the years I lived there in
nine of them never seen the levees that
high